when you think cyber security you should
think CIA no not those Spy Guys a
different kind of CIA what I mean is
confidentiality
integrity
and availability
these three things make up something
that we call the CIA Triad and let's
talk about those ideas in a little more
detail so first of all confidentiality
that's the idea that says only an
authorized user should be able to see
particular information or access
particular resources so in order to do
that let's take an example where we've
got let's say this guy is an authorized
user and he wants to be able to read
this particular data so what would we do
well we'd probably put in place some
sort of security system some sort of
authentication authorization
multi-factor authentication uh some sort
of encryption capability so that when he
goes to access this he is given access
and gets it but on the other hand if we
have an unauthorized user who wants to
do the same thing they try to get into
the system and they are blocked so
that's really what confidentiality is
about it's a very simple concept it's a
lot harder to implement a lot of times
if you look at the literature it will
refer to confidentiality as the same as
privacy but I'll say that's kind of
based on an older notion of what privacy
is now we have a more modern notion that
says confidentiality really involves
more things like notice and consent and
the right to be forgotten and things
like that that's not really covered in
this overall notion of confidentiality
but it is still very important
so confidentiality the first of the CIA
Triad how about next Integrity well
Integrity basically means that if I
place an order for let's say a hundred
widgets that someone can't come along
later and turn that into a hundred
thousand Widgets or a million or change
the number entirely or delete the record
entirely in other words the information
is trustworthy it is true to itself as
another way to think of it so with
Integrity Technologies what we do is
we're looking for tampering and we're
detecting that and then alerting someone
so that they know that this data is no
longer trustworthy a bad guy for
instance might try to come into a system
after he's hacked it and change the log
file to remove any record that he was
there in the first place that would be
an Integrity attack so we need security
capabilities to ensure that the system
is still true to itself
and then the last part of the CIA Triad
is availability in this case it's about
making sure that authorized users have
access to the resources that they need
when they need them so for instance we
have authorized user here and they want
to access a particular server so when
they come they get access as they expect
however we could end up with a case
where we have a malicious actor who
comes in and floods this system with too
much traffic therefore taking it down
making it not available we refer to this
as an as a denial of service attack
and a denial of service attack can take
a lot of different forms but that's the
basic idea is that a bad guy is
preventing a good guy from getting
access to the system so when it comes
down to security again think CIA not the
Spy Guys but the CIA Triad and use that
as a checklist whenever you come up with
a new security project go back over this
the different angles of the CIA Triad
and say did I cover confidentiality did
I cover Integrity attacks did I cover
availability and if I've got all of
those things covered then it's job
finished